Robb's world hey guys this is Rob's
world and welcome to my tutorial for
thee we didn't just stop this is the
cool ninja star that Jeremy Shafer
designed thank you very much for your
comments on my last video for the paper
wallet I got a lot of comments they're
asking to make a triple ninja star cuz I
showed one at the end but check out what
happened when I through it alright nice
it's done and now to test it out fail
epic fail man it's just not flying well
well hey Jeremy its Rob did you figure
out that triple a ninja star design yet
yeah it got it right here
hold on I'll show it to you look out
your front door wait what
oh did you get it yeah man this is
pretty awesome
lettuce butter too huh hey you should
definitely teach it on your channel and
it's pretty sharp too I'm sure they're
gonna like it the triple ninja star or
ninja Tristar is a type of modular
origami meaning we're going to interlock
each of these individual units together
in order to get the ninja star if you're
going to use origami paper make sure
that the white side is facing up like
this when you start I'm using three
colored sheets of letter-sized paper to
make it into a square I take the top
edge and fold it down to the left side
and then I tear it along this edge here
now that we have a fold going this way
we're going to take the upper left
corner and fold it down to the lower
right corner line up the edges and then
make a crease along the edge here
now you'll see we have an X in the paper
once again just fold it on the diagonal
and we're going to take this lower edge
here and we're going to take both of
these layers and fold them up to this
edge so you can just kind of hold it
like this and line this edge up with the
top once everything's lined up then you
can make a crease now you'll see we have
a big triangle here on the left and a
right triangle over here on the right
we're going to take this edge of the
smaller triangle and we're going to fold
it up so that it meets this edge which
we just fold it in right here so you can
just take it like this it's probably
easier to set it down but just so you
could see fold it up like that line up
the edges and then crease it
now we're going to flip the model around
and I'm going to take this edge here
that we just made and I'm going to fold
it up to the top edge right here take it
fold it up and then you can hold it
right here make sure that edge is all
lined up and then you can make that
crease if you're using printer paper
it's gonna get a little bit thick here
so just be sure to hold it nice and
tight when you're folding it once again
we're going to take this bottom edge and
fold it up to the top here it gets a
little bit thick so be sure to hold it
snug right here with your right hand now
if you fold it up you'll see this corner
right here will actually join with this
corner that's right here so just hold it
join those corners up pinch it and then
make a crease along the bottom it's a
little thick but just crease it as best
you can
now you can actually unfold this corner
by grabbing this corner here and just
pull it out just like that and this
corner which is tucked in you could just
unfold this as well so your paper should
look something like this now we're going
to fold this edge right here along this
crease which we made so you just want to
fold on that crease right here
just like that
we're going to take this corner and
we're going to fold it in by taking this
edge and aligning it with this edge of
the paper
so it's easier if you kind of hold it
like this then you could easily take
that edge hold this down with your left
hand so it's nice and flush with the
paper and make sure that that edge lines
up with the other edge then you can make
that crease there okay so now that this
corner is folded in we're going to take
this edge of the paper here and we're
going to join it with this edge as well
so what you do fold that in like that
and you could just pinch it like this
now as you'll see on the paper there
actually is a crease that goes
diagonally like this however we need to
make a new crease right next to it where
this corner meets the paper we need to
make a mark right there now if you want
to be really precise and you're using
eight-and-a-half by eleven paper the
mark that you're going to make is
exactly five millimetres half a
centimeter to the left of the bottom of
this crease right there if you follow
this little crease all the way to the
top right at the top here is where we're
going to make the second mark now I'm
going to draw a line so that you could
see it a little easier so as you'll see
it's just a little bit off from the main
mark and the reason that we're doing
this is because this angle that we're
going to make has to be 120 degrees now
we're going to take this bottom edge and
we're going to fold it up so that it
lies directly on that line we just drew
put your fingernail right here in the
corner and pull up now you can lay that
edge directly on that line all the way
to the top just like that and then make
a crease along the bottom here so you
should have something that looks just
like this
now you can unfold this and just flatten
it out now we're going to take this part
of the paper and we're going to fold
directly on this crease here right where
my finger is we're going to take this
paper and we're going to fold up like
this and we're going to take the rest of
this paper here and we're going to wrap
it around just like this you want to
pull it nice and tight it's not gonna
quite line up at the bottom here but
that's okay now you'll see we have a
little flap here and we have a pocket
right in here you want to take this flap
and you're gonna fold it down so that
the fold lines up with the top of the
pocket just like that now you can open
the pocket and you can tuck this flap in
as far as it can go just like that
there you go that's how to make the
modular three-point tristar unit once
you've made three then we can interlock
them if you take a look at the unit
you'll notice there's a pocket here on
the front where we tucked in that flat
there's a pocket on the back of the same
side it's a little bit thinner and
there's also a point here we're going to
flip all three of the units upside down
so that this thinner pocket is on the
top then we could take two of the units
we're going to take this point that
doesn't have the pocket and we're going
to join it with the thin pocket here
that doesn't have that little flap so
you're just gonna take two pieces like
this
you're gonna take the point and you're
gonna put it right in the pocket just
like that and just use your thumb to
kind of push it down now we're going to
take the other one and just remember
we're holding it so that the pocket
where the flap was tucked in is on the
back again we're going to take this
point and we're going to put it into the
thin pocket right here on this piece now
and slide that all the way in we're
going to take this third piece that we
just tucked in and we're going to take
this part with the pockets and we're
going to put it underneath the tip of
the first one the blue one just gonna
take it and slide that underneath like
that you'll see this is the point of the
blue piece we're gonna bend it and put
it in this little sleeve or pocket of
the yellow piece which is the third
piece so all you need to do is to round
this off a little bit put that inside
all the way in and just use your thumb
to kind of push it
then you can kind of set it down flatten
everything out and there you go you have
the triple ninja star now as you'll
notice it is a little bit concave
meaning these points are actually bent a
little bit to the left like that when
you see these tabs on the right if you
didn't make the guide mark correctly or
if you fold it at the existing crease
this is what would happen now I'll show
you how to throw it all right so I found
that the best way to to throw it is to
have these little tabs on the back
facing to the right so you want to hold
it just like this in your right hand if
your lefty then you can throw it like
this hold it like this and you're gonna
throw it overhand and let it spin out of
your hand if you want to try to throw it
sideways you can do that as well let's
see if I could hit my portrait
oh it came apart thank you guys very
much for watching this video be sure to
subscribe by clicking this little button
down here thank you very much again to
Jeremy for showing me this awesome
design let me know what you guys thought
of this video leave me a comment below
and also let me know what you want to
see next and we'll see you next time